[Music]
thank you
it is at 10 o'clock this is Sky News at
10 our top story nickel sturgeon says
she had no prior knowledge of the
police's intentions to arrest her
husband
Peter Murrell has been questioned by
police as part of an ongoing
investigation into the finances of the
SMP this is a difficulty for the party
but again I've just reiterate and
emphasize it's so important for me not
to comment on a live police
investigation
also tonight at least 850 arrests
connected to online child sex offenses
every month revealed in new data seen by
Sky News we have a special report I felt
dirty
that was how it made me feel
that I've been with somebody who has
done those things
[Music]
a giant barge will be used to house 500
migrants in Dorset we get the reaction
from some Asylum seekers in the UK
walking side by side to Victory a
message of strength from the Ukrainian
president in his first visit to
neighboring Poland since the War Began
Trump gets a boost in the polls since
being charged in New York we take a
closer look at the case and what it
means for the presidential election
[Music]
and the king and queen consorts soon to
be at Queen Camilla get a tour and a
taste of Yorkshire
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview at 10 30.
foreign
good evening there have been police
vehicles and an Evidence tent outside
the home of the former Scottish first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon today after
her husband Peter Morrill was arrested
and questioned in connection with the
funding and finances of the Scottish
national party Mr Morrill stood down as
the smp's chief executive last month
following a long investigation by the
police but as tonight's been released
without charge now miss sturgeon has
said she had no prior knowledge of the
arrest and will not be commenting on an
ongoing investigation the development
was given Hamza Youssef his first big
test as the new first Minister and
leader of the s p Skies Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies reports
[Applause]
it is the home of model and sturgeon
until last week Scotland's political
power couple now the epicenter of a
police probe
the occupants were out and the
detectives were in Peter model the man
who was the smp's chief executive for
decades was in custody for 12 hours
questioned before being released over
the party's fundraising and finances
this the first big test for the new
first Minister Hamza Yusuf I was told
this morning after the event
um and of course my reaction as you'd
imagine much like anybody involved in
the SNP is that this is a difficulty for
the party but again I've just reiterate
and emphasized it's so important for me
not to comment on a live police
investigation and see be seen to
Prejudice that in any way shape or form
this is the snp's Edinburgh headquarters
also at the heart of this investigation
police posing questions about six
hundred thousand pounds raised for a
second referendum campaign
this is an extraordinary moment an
embarrassing episode for a party known
for its discipline the question is will
this probe overshadow Nicholas
sturgeon's Legacy after more than 3 000
days in the highest office and will she
too face questions about what she did or
did not know I mean I like the SMP for a
long time so I'm very sad about what's
happening to it and they did about what
it's become but uh who should remember
the cause of Independence and the case
for it has never been stronger and
that's what myself and Oliver
concentrating on putting forward
here Nicholas sturgeon questioned in one
of her last interviews as first Minister
but that's a suggestion you and your
husband will be interviewed have you
heard anything on that but no but I am
not going to comment on I wouldn't
comment on any ongoing police
investigation and I'm not going to
comment on this one
have you been questioned two on the day
she resigned and
a statement saying she had no knowledge
of police Scotland's actions or
intentions and she will fully cooperate
if required but this is the couple's
Back Garden police bagging evidence amid
a two-year investigation culminating in
the arrest of a man once in charge of
Scotland's biggest political party
what Conor is loafer is now in Glasgow
good evening to you Connor so it's been
quite the day for the SMP
fully detained Peter model at 7 45 this
morning and released just before seven
o'clock this evening in a day of
questions for the former chief executive
of the SMP uh questioned under caution
for 12 hours and that was the question
around whether the prosecution service
and detectives here in Scotland uh what
they would do at that point would they
apply for additional time for questions
would they bring about any possible
charges or would they release Peter
Morrow without charge pending further
inquiries and it was that latter option
that police here in Scotland took this
tent that we were seeing in my report
there is usually reserved for very major
police investigations it has been a day
of drama Nicholas sturgeon has said
herself that she will cooperate with the
police if they come looking if they come
looking for answers and wanting to pose
further questions but she has not been
seen in public at all throughout the
course of today
okay Connor Gillies for now thank you
well in new data seen by Sky News it's
been revealed that there are more than
800 child sex abuse arrests every month
in England and Wales and about a third
of those arrested have children living
with them at the time in an exclusive
interview senior police officers told
Sky News that families of sex offenders
are often the hidden victims of their
crimes and if authorities don't get it
right the impact on children will last
for the rest of their lives Katarina
vertotsi has this special report
families call it the knock
and it's life-changing
police at the door is the way most
families learn their partner or parent
is suspected of online child sex
offenses it was the way the nightmare
started for Jessica and her three
children who were all under 12. you feel
I felt
dirty
that was how it made me feel
that I've been with somebody who has
done those things
and for your children and for my
children the same again especially my
daughter because that was
how to even begin to comprehend
that was somebody who was an amazing dad
and somebody you look up to has done
something like that new data shared with
Sky News shows that every month in
England and Wales there are more than
800 arrests in connection with online
child sex abuse and researchers say that
35 of those people that's about 300 a
month have children living with them at
the time of their arrest
and the stigma and shame of their
parents arrest and offense can be
traumatic
we had to move away
or had to move schools we had to change
our names
and when I went to see David in prison
I wasn't allowed to sit on his knee
I am not allowed to say his name in
school because I will get attacked by my
friends everyone says I can't love him
but
I can't stop
their stories are hard to hear but these
children aren't defined as victims under
the current government victims code in
fact they get less automatic support
things like counseling than the offender
does in an exclusive interview with Sky
News the British police lead on Child
Protection says families of sex
offenders are hidden victims and they
could be legally defined as such
that's under discussion that's a clearly
a matter that comes under statute under
the victims victim's code you know
almost the removal of a parent
out of their house in such a dramatic
and impactive way clearly requires uh
Mental Health Services for for children
we will also very much focus on the
children and the partners Left Behind as
you describe who are the hidden victims
of this some forces recognize there's a
gap here but a new report found that
police support schemes aimed at families
are still missing children police forces
and also officers and staff are missing
opportunities to make sure that children
who are either who have access to
suspects all who live in the home that
they receive the right information and
the right support
[Music]
the government says there are no plans
to adapt the victim's code to
incorporate families like Jessica's who
feel invisible vulnerable and very alone
Katrina Vuitton Sky News
now the home office has confirmed it has
leased a barge big enough for 500 Asylum
Seekers which is going to be docked off
the coast of Dorset the government
argues the accommodation described as
basic and functional will be better
value for the taxpayer than offering
rooms in hotels but two people currently
being housed in hotels have told Sky
News that they would refuse to move to
the barge our communities correspondent
Lisa Holland has this
it's not just the government talking
tough on the Asylum crisis the man in
the orange top from Sudan is the
self-starred leader of this group of
Asylum Seekers they're feeling angry
every day between them they've all moved
from two hotels in East London where
there were standoffs with the home
office refusing to leave before finally
agreeing to be transferred to new
accommodation an hour and a half away
they say they won't move to another
hotel let alone a barge if you get asked
to move again to another hotel
no no no no no no I I can't move
I can't move
I will make protest
all or all the people here I I invite
them to make protests in front of hotel
what do you say to people who say your
accommodation is being paid for by the
British taxpayer so the government can
send you to whichever Hotel they want to
I have been near to to be two years how
can I you're saying you're settled yeah
yeah
the home office won't say exactly who is
destined for its three-story floating
barge the Bibby Stockholm currently in
Port in Genoa in Italy it will be
birthed in Portland Harbor much to the
opposition of Dorset Council and house
500 Asylum seekers in what the
government describes as basic
accommodation we're bringing forward
alternative sites like indeed the barge
that we've announced today that will
save us money and indeed reduce pressure
on hotels all part of our plan to stop
the boat currently six million pounds a
day is being spent on housing 51 000
Asylum seekers in hundreds of hotels
this man from Sudan has been in six of
them in three years if the government
tries to send you to a barge what will
be your reaction
uh no I don't want to go
I don't want to go anymore you don't you
say you don't want to go but what what
will you do I I got homeless
by homeless he means he'll disappear
from the Asylum system living outside of
society something we're increasingly
hearing from people who also say they're
afraid of being sent to Rwanda
yet hours before the government's barge
announcement Sky News filmed three boats
packed with migrants leaving a beach in
Dunkirk in northern France
those who successfully make the journey
will arrive as the government continues
to unveil a strategy aimed at deterring
people from trying to cross the channel
Lisa Holland Sky News
now the Russian President Vladimir Putin
welcomed his Belarusian counterpart
Alexander lukashenko to Moscow today to
begin two days of talks but in their
opening remarks both men avoided
mentioning Ukraine saying they'll
discuss the war tomorrow meanwhile
President Vladimir zelenski has visited
Poland in his first official visit since
Russia's invasion of Ukraine while
Poland has provided four
soviets-designed MiG-29 fighter jets to
Ukraine and the Polish president said
more planes were being prepared our
correspondent Siobhan Robbins reports
now from Warsaw
foreign
from the start this was a meeting of
friends a display of warmth of
solidarity
in Poland president zielinski was
treated to a hero's welcome as he
visited his closest neighbor
his counterpart gave him the full red
carpet treatment
the troops greeted him as a respected
leader
outside some of the million Ukrainian
refugees given Shelter by Poland were
among fans hoping to get a glimpse of
him
I'm very excited honestly my hottest
bitter right now I I want to see him I
want to see him at least like from from
the distance I think he's a really
superhero like nowadays superhero like
he's amazing man
the Polish president clearly shared
their sentiment presenting one of
Poland's highest Awards to zelenski who
in return was deeply thankful
I want to thank you for the fact that
you our powerful neighbors did not and
do not allow us to break for the fact
that you help us if Ukraine Falls we
know that Russia will not stop there and
will go further
and there is a lot to be grateful for a
few hours away in the Polish Countryside
Ukrainian troops were being trained to
use leopard two tanks
Poland's Been instrumental in helping to
secure weapons and aid for Ukraine
a small price according to president
Duda for the sacrifices being made
across the border
[Applause]
no one expected Ukraine would stand for
so long the Defenders of Ukraine would
be so heroic
deals were also done to supply more
weapons in the future and build a
lasting relationship
this trip isn't just about reaffirming
friendship it's also about building
credit for the future the longer the war
goes on the more it affects people
living in neighboring countries like
this and Ukraine knows it has to keep
the public on side to ensure support
going forward
for now that isn't a problem zelenski
has stolen the hearts of many in this
nation Siobhan Robbins Sky News Poland
foreign
police entered the compound and tried to
remove worshipers video on social media
has emerged which appears to show
Israeli police beating people inside the
mosque last night Ramadan and Passover
coincide this year and there are fears
of a further escalation in violence now
a warning that this report by Sky's
Middle East correspondent as the bunkel
shows police appearing to beat
worshipers
for a second night running Israeli
police and Palestinian worshipers
clashed into Al-Aqsa mosque compound in
Jerusalem
the site of Israeli riot police
attacking Palestinians inside the prayer
during Ramadan
has put Jerusalem and the Middle East on
edge again
[Music]
Israeli police say several hundred men
illegally remained in the mosque after
prayers on Tuesday night and they
initially tried to negotiate with them
to leave
Al-Aqsa mosque sits on top of Temple
mount the holiest site for Jews
at this religious time of year many
Palestinians fear that extremist Jewish
groups will come and pray at the site as
part of a movement to slowly push
Muslims out of the compound
some of the worshipers refused to leave
they were armed with wooden clubs rocks
and fireworks and so the police went in
the clashes went on into the early hours
of the morning what do you feel when you
see the soldier beat your son what
angry sad what nobody can deny that is
this is terrors
terrors
in response Rockets were fired from the
Gaza Strip into Southern Israel most
were either intercepted or landed in
Oakland ground one hit a factory but
there were no injuries
the Israeli military hit back striking
targets belonging to Hamas the militant
Group which controls Gaza the resistance
sent its message in gunpowder last night
by responding to the aggression it's a
clear message to the occupation if this
aggression continues there will be a
large open-ended war with the Zionist
occupation
for a second year running the holy
Muslim month of Ramadan and the Jewish
Festival of Passover coincide
[Applause]
it was always going to be a tense period
but especially after violence has been
escalating in the West Bank this year
Jordan as custodians of Alexa mosque
called for an emergency meeting of the
Arab League
Israel says it doesn't want an
escalation but is ready if it happens
Alistar bunkel's Sky News
I want to just bring you a little bit of
breaking news that's coming in the last
few minutes the story that we've been
bringing you throughout this evening
about the conservative MP for Blackpool
at South Scott Benton he was involved in
a Stig operation as you can see here put
on by the Times newspaper and uh it's
now transpires that Mr Benton has been
uh had the party whip suspended pending
an investigation by the conservative
Chief whip Simon Hart following the
publication of this footage it appears
to show in the footage of Mr Benton
offering to Lobby ministers on behalf of
the gambling industry Scott Benton is
the chair of the all party parliamentary
committee on betting and gaming and as
we can see from this footage held a
meeting with a fictitious company that
was looking to influence ministers
around a change to the law that's uh
belong in the works for how the gambling
industry is regulated Mr Benton held
that meeting and from the footage that
has been released by The Times newspaper
this evening seemed to be willing to to
Lobby ministers and offer sensitive
information to this company ahead of the
publication of that new law now Mr
Benton did not receive any money and
said that once he had held that meeting
with those undercover journalists did
refer it to the Parliamentary committee
responsible
four approaches for these kind of things
but in the past hour Simon Hart has
confirmed the conservative party Chief
whip that Scott Benton has lost the
party whip
now Donald Trump is going to be in court
again on the 4th of December after
pleading not guilty yesterday to 34
counts of falsifying business records
now despite his legal issues he still
wants to be the Republican nominee in
next year's U.S presidential election
and some even think that what's going on
could help his chances our U.S
correspondent Martha Kellner reports now
on the case that's dividing America
an American the circus was familiar but
the circumstance unique the former
president speaking for the first time as
a criminal defendant
walking to the stage like a boxer to the
ring and this was classic Donald Trump
counter punching light on the facts and
heavy on the attacks I never thought
anything like this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it this fake
case was brought only to interfere with
the upcoming 2024 election
and it should be dropped immediately
impossible to get inside Donald Trump's
head to know what he's really thinking
beneath the bravado but somewhere Behind
These Walls at Mar-A-Lago he is still
digesting the full detail of the case
against him his allies in the Tabloid
media have come out to back him they
think these are trumped-up charges too
polling shows those who supported him
before still do would this indictment
affect whether you vote for him or not
no no not at all no it just seems like a
ploy by the Democratic party trying to
make sure that he's not able to run side
by side in restaurants and bars across
America people with wildly different
views I was in high school when George W
Bush was elected and I remember thinking
like oh this is terrible like we don't
want someone who's conservative in
office like I disagree with this man and
I am now longing for the days of a Bush
Junior Senior reagan-esque country
but in the Sunshine State there is the
possibility that Donald Trump could be
eclipsed by a rival close to home
Rhonda santis Florida's governor a man
with trumpian politics is also likely to
run to be the Republican nominee in
2024. oh I absolutely would vote for
Iran but I think it would do us all or
would do the Republican Party Justice if
Donald Trump would just step back and
promote a new candidate
thank you
Trump though Remains the most likely
Challenger for the White House despite
the possibility that he may be on trial
when campaigning begins it would be
another breathtaking chapter in a
political career which continues to
divide this country Martha Kellner Sky
News Florida
let's take a look now in some more
detail at the case being brought against
the former president our data and
forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire has
been analyzing the charges
Donald Trump pleaded not guilty to 34
counts of falsifying business records in
the first degree in a New York courtroom
yesterday and we'll get to the
consequences the questions raised by the
case but let's start with the charges
now each count has to do with payments
to former Trump lawyer Michael Cohen
who's already served prison time for
paying hush money for the president to
form our adult film actress Stormy
Daniels and that is probably the best
known case a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars was repaid to Mr Kern after he
paid Miss Daniels to stay quiet about
her alleged sexual encounter with Trump
back in 2006. Mr Trump denies he slept
with Daniels but he has acknowledged
paying Cohen the money another payment
thirty thousand dollars was made through
Ami American Media Inc the corporate
parent of the Tabloid newspaper National
Enquirer that was to buy The Silence of
a former Trump Tower doorman who is
claiming apparently falsely that Trump
fathered a child out of wedlock and
prosecutors also claimed that am I paid
playable model Karen McDougall a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in exchange
for her agreement not to speak out about
the alleged affair with Trump in 2006.
and district attorney Alvin Bragg
described this practice as a catch and
kill scheme to boost Trump's electoral
prospects this involves identifying
negative information buying that
information through means like hush
money and then suppressing it now all of
that might sound familiar because we
have heard a lot of it before but
usually these would be classed as
misdemeanors falsifying business records
rather than felonies but they're being
charged as felonies because the New York
prosecutor wants to prove the records
were falsified with an intent to commit
Aid or conceal another crime in this
case the D.A says the crime was attempts
to violate state and federal election
laws now each count carries a maximum
penalty of four years in prison but even
if Trump is found guilty many legal
experts thinks it's unlikely he would
serve prison time and the case isn't
expected to go into trial until next
year so it could be well into the 2024
presidential campaign before we have a
conclusion
Tom Cheshire reporting there now the
king and queen consort have been in
Yorkshire today meeting people in the
town of Moulton it was revealed last
night that the queen consult will be
addressed as Queen Camilla after the
coronation our correspondent shingi
marike has been finding out what people
think of the change in title
the king and queen consort stepping out
to the sounds of a traditional Yorkshire
Brass Band and a warm welcome seen in
public for the first time since news of
a new title for Camilla
one confirmed cemented and celebrated on
this coronation invitation sent on
behalf of their Majesty's King Charles
III and queen Camilla yes I like to work
with Citrus driver they were in molting
today meeting independent food and drink
businesses sampling some treats as they
went along and Sir Charles drank the
coffee and he had some Gin so we've had
to buy of course what Charles had
haven't we
people here say the change of title is a
moment she deserves
I mean she's married to the king so yeah
I mean it is what it is
new for the country so yeah I think
she's earned it I think it's it's his
choice it's his wife
for experts this is simply about
following tradition this shift is
actually kind of just giving her her
proper title if we can call it that
because we talk about King Charles so
it's natural to say queen Camilla rather
than Queen consort and you only have to
look back to the Queen Mother Queen Mary
Queen Alexandra before that and it's
just the normal way that Queen's consult
are referred to
it's a time that has heralded so much
change but with this certainty and
clarity
from the day they're crowned they will
simply be the king and queen
shinki marike Sky News Moulton in North
Yorkshire